Hey, welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
This is Episode 100, so we're gonna try something special.
Let me explain!
So, at the moment, we still use this gas, which is natural gas.
But, it's a fossil fuel and we prefer to try something else.
So I want to try to see if we can use
our food scraps to produce gas.
For this, we're gonna prototype a biodigester,
and we have some friends coming over to help us out.
But, first, we're gonna continue a little
bit of work in our pig trailer!
We're gonna make the floor!
- In the previous videos, you saw us choose
and buy this pig trailer.
We restored it and start building our new home.
In the last update, we waterproofed it,
and now, it's time to put the floor.
We need to get some materials which we can reuse.
- So, we're in a local scrapyard,
and we found some plywood.
Old plywood, but it's still in good condition.
We will try to reuse it.
We have also found some really cool insulation!
It's plastic-y, but I guess it still works.
I like challenges.
Go to the university,
and you'll learn how to make all this.
So, when we restored the trailer, we had to take
some rotten wooden boards out of the sides.
Apart from that, the rest is in quite good condition.
Wouter is filling the gaps with wooden buttons
that we had left from the structure build.
Next, we'll place the insulation that
we found in the scrapyard.
The first layer is in!
Now, a second one.
Then, it's time for the reused plywood boards.
- The insulation is in, which was the green stuff you saw.
Two layers, with on top a layer of multiplex.
This is second hand multiplex.
You can see little holes, and cracks.
It's still usable as an underfloor.
Now, we're going to tape the seams.
Because, there is the biggest risk of air
blowing in on a windy day...
And then, it's really not good for your insulation.
So, this is something we want to tape.
And then, we can finish it with the foil taped on,
and it's all nice and closed.
Cool! Let's start!
- Okay, so, while Wouter is finishing that tape,
I'm gonna start prepping a few boards here.
We're gonna put the same basketball court on the floor again.
There's a lot of dirt in the joints that we have to take out.
And also, we have to cut out the ends,
which are filled with glue.
Last piece!
- That was it!
Okay, that was it for this week on the pig trailer.
We now have a nice floor.
- You happy?
Nice basketball floor.
- So next, we're going to build our first prototype of a biodigester.
But, I can imagine you don't know how it works.
So, Adrian will first briefly explain what it actually is.
- What's a biodigester?
It's basically an airtight container, where we host bacteria
that ferment organic matter without oxygen.
We can feed it with food leftovers.
Then, the bacteria do their magic, and after some days...
We get methane we can use in a stove,
and liquid fertilizer for the plants.
There are many types.
Some quite big, even industrial scale.
Some more DIY, underground, portable or automatized.
What we want is a basic one,
that we can build ourselves.
To get a start with this technology,
and see if it's interesting for us.
Okay let's start on our bio digester.
For this, we have the help of Fabio, who is coming from
Instituto Favela de Paz, where he does incredible work.
Instituto Favela de Paz is a project based in Sao Paulo,
Brazil in the favela of Jardim Angela.
They promote a more peaceful living by
developing educational projects around sustainability.
engaging with the community through technology music and arts.
Among many other projects, like recycled street lights,
solar panels, technology workshops or urban gardening...
They also build biodigesters.
As Fabio was visiting Portugal, we asked him
to come andhelp us build our prototype.
His designs are simple, not expensive and easy to replicate.
He also brought some friends!
Meet Gui, Lu and Jorge!
They will assist us and help us with the building.
First thing we need is an ICB container of 1000 liters.
An ICB is a very common plastic
container used in many agricultural settings.
We found ours in a secondhand scrapyard.
We will also need two barrels,
with one slightly bigger than the other.
Now, we need to paint it all black.
Because, we need to avoid the sunlight to go in,
in order to not let the algae grow inside.
So, the next step is disassembling this, paint the thing black,
go back and then we can start the building.
- Step two is cleaning.
Step three: painting the primary layer.
The next step is painting on the black!
I think it needs another layer after this.
No light can peek through.
All right! Now, it's completely black!
We're gonna assemble it back together.
- We have the ICB ready.
Now, we need to prepare the blue barrels.
We're gonna cut the top of this container,
in order to put the other inside.
So, I'm just gonna help them with that.
Now, we are gonna make the hole for
the feeder.
We will use this lid already that is well sealed underneath.
So, it doesn't let the air go out,
but we put the pipe in and we can feed it easily.
Now, we are drilling the hole for some piping.
This is gonna be the outlet of our biodigester.
It's gonna bring the gas from the top of the tank.
We have two exitpoints.
One will be to test the flame, to do tests basically.
That's why it has a little tap.
This will be the outlet for the gas that will go to our storage.
So, for all the connections in the top part of the biodigester,
we are using rubber in order to make it airtight.
This will be the mouth of our biodigester.
So, we are gonna cut it here at 45 degrees, and put it inside.
This is a 50 millimeter pipe that we are gonna cut,
and it's gonna be the for circuit of our biofertilizer.
It will go to more or less the middle of the tank,
go out another corner and then we will collect it outside.
How is it going Fabio?
It will go to this bucket.
Now, it's time to start with the gasometer
It will consist in a tank that would be
up and down storing our gas.
And, creating the pressure that is needed
to bring the gas to the stove.
For the gasometer, we need to build some sort of a cage.
So, when the barrel fills with the gas,
it will go up, but not out.
Now, we are going to install the inlet
of the gas in our gasometer.
And, the outlet that would go to our stove.
We will put it a bit in the side,
in order to avoid the cage to touch this piece.
Okay! Now, it's time to build the cage!
We now have the gasometer and the biodigester.
We just need to connect it together.
Here it is!
We finally put together all the pieces of the puzzle!
And, our biodigesting system is ready to be fed and tested.
Here is where our food scraps go in.
This is where our biofertilizer will come out.
And, here is where we can test the flame of the bio digester.
This is our gasometer where we store our biogas.
This is the place where the
gas comes in and out to our stove.
Now, it's time to feed it!
This is going to be fun.
We were preparing a nice starter for a week already.
Let me show you what it is!
We went to see our neighbor Jorge
to get some manure from his cows.
We mix it with water and we left it
to rest into the blue barrel.
Now, we have it ready.
Now, we are filling it up with water, until we seal this pipe,
that gets to more or less half of the container.
Now, we are going to put some bacteria 'hotels'.
They are going tofloat and increase
the surface where they can live.
So, the bacteria can stick to that.
Now, the last step is to put water in between both barrels,
in order to seal the gas in the top one.
We finished our biodigester!
Now, we need to move it to
its final location, in the blue tent.
We couldn't do this before, because Kevin was
still renovating it, as you have seen in Update 96.
So, now, we need to move a lot of heavy liquid poop.
Great...
Luckily, Jorge came to help us out with his tractor.
- Alright, so, here we have it!
The final prototype of the bio digester!
Unfortunately, there is no big flame yet, or gas being produced...
Because, it takes a while before the bacteria do that.
And, it probably also requires some tweaking from our side
tofind the right temperature and pH level.
But, you can find more of that in the research module,
where we will continue to post updates.
Or, subscribe on YouTube and see how it's going to go.
Because, we're probably also going to make some upgrades
to the whole system of installing a shredder.
That makes it easier for the food to go in!
Yeah, so, this is not the last time you've seen this guy.
But, for now, it's time to move on,
because it's grape-picking time.
It's that time of the year where it's time to harvest the grapes,
and we're going to help out the neighbors.
And, I'm also going to introduce you to a new lady,
that you might have already seen in the previous videos!
But now, she's going to join us in
actually picking all the grapes.
Let's go!
- Hello, my name's Ingrid!
I'm half Dutch, half English and I consider
myself to be the granny of the group.
You'll often find me in my pajamas doing some cross stitch, baking bread,
sneaking biscuits from the kitchen, or reading by the lagoon.
Before coming to Project Kamp, I was working at YouTube
and finishing my masters in AI-ethics.
My passion is helping people disconnect from technology,
and reconnect with nature.
Which, is why I decided to get out from behind my desk,
turn away from my screen and head off to Portugal!
To chop trees and get my hands dirty!
Okay, now, we can go grape picking!
So, today, a bunch of us are heading over to our neighbors,
Antonio and Fernanda, as they need a couple extra hands picking grapes.
This over here is their field.
A bunch of the team is already out there.
So, let's see if we can help!
Perfect! Tincho, how can I help?
- You can grab these buckets, and some clippers there.
Kevin and Alice, have you gone grape picking before?
- This is the first time.
How is it?
Wow!
- Yeah, it's good!
Tasty?
Very sweet.
- It already looks beautiful.
It's nice.
You want to have one?
- Please!
Dorian, if you can take some of these grapes home,
is there anything you can make with them?
I would flavor some Kombucha with it.
You can make some wine,
but I don't have the tools for it...
Antonio turned 70 today.
He was just saying
the secrets of staying fit.
- Ah, grape picking!
Is that the secret?
- Yes.
Keeping on working.
Chester has discovered the fallen grape.
Are they tasty, Chester?
Okay, that's it for this afternoon.
We spent three hours with 13 people,
picking all of the grapes here in the vineyard.
And, we have loaded up the truck
three times full of buckets of grapes.
So, now, it is time to go and enjoy some wine.
This is where they leave the wine now for five days.
- All right, so, after that celebration we actually have another one,
because this is a special video -- number 100!
It took over three years
to actually get to this point.
Many videos uploaded, many people came to help out,
and also all of you guys!
Thanks for watching and making this possible!
So, now, a little toast with Antonio's wine.
All right, so, that was it for this video!
If you already want to see the next one...
Where we're going to install a new solar system,
and continue working on the pig trailer...
Make sure to subscribe and support on Patreon!
You can then already see the next video
one week ahead, in 4K without advertisements.
Or not, just subscribe and you can see it next week!
Same channel, same time.
Thank you for watching!
Here's to 200 videos!